There're only four paths to getting
ultra wealthy. I crossed $100 million
net worth by age 31, and then I started
acquisition.com, our investment firm. I
spent the next year studying how to go
from 100 million to a billion. And there
are four paths, we'll start with the
first. So, in the first path, you have
other
people's
money
being invested into your
business.
Now, let's look at some of the business
titans that followed this path.
So, here you can see three pie charts
with 17%, 10%, and 4%. If I were to show
you this and say, "Do you think the
people who own these pies are very
rich?" You might think, "Well, no, they
own so little of the pie." But if I then
said, "This is Tesla,
this is Amazon,
and this is Nvidia."
Would you all of a sudden then think,
"Oh, wait, this is Jensen Huang,
Elon,
and Bezos."
Some of the richest people in the world,
who are all centibillionaires, and now
at this point multi-centibillionaires.
And so, these incredibly successful
people understood the first path of
getting ultra wealthy, which is
the combination of other people's money
into your business. Now, the way that it
works is that you raise funds by selling
a percentage of your company. So, what
this does is that it actually dilutes
you as a founder, meaning you no longer
earn own 100% of your company, but now
you might own 80% of a company that now
has an extra $20 million, for example,
that you can then use to grow. Now,
there are some businesses that this is
the only strategy to successfully
realistically accomplish the goal, and
then there are some businesses that this
would be a terrible idea to pursue. Now,
one thing that I think took me way too
long to understand as an entrepreneur is
that every single business incurs debt
the moment you start it. The question is
what type of debt you're going to incur.
And so, for example, if you bootstrap a
business, as in you take no outside
capital when you start it, you just fund
it yourself, and then you own it, and
you grow it organically, then the debt
that you take on is going to be that
you're not going to have enough money to
get the best talent in the door. And so,
you're going to have talent debt. You're
probably not going to have enough money
to get the right technological
infrastructure in place to to to run the
entire business, so you'll take on
technological debt, right? And you can
go down the line so they can have all
the other ancillary non-financial
versions of debt. Now, businesses that
choose to take on financial debt choose
to take on that debt instead of the
other types of debt because of the
nature of the competitive dynamics of
the market they're in. And so, those
types of businesses typically are in
businesses that take a tremendous amount
of capital to start up and scale, or
they're in winner-take-all markets,
where speed is the primary objective of
the business so that they can capture
the opportunity and then fundamentally
become monopolies of a new type. So,
Facebook, for example, became a monopoly
of attention to a large degree. Now,
because there are other social media
platforms, they get away with that, but
they have created a big moat around all
of the attention that exists in media.
And so, for them, there's only one real
big social network that was going to
exist. And so, they then captured it. Of
course, LinkedIn was like, well, is
there a version of that we can do for
business professionals? And then they
captured that. Now, can you imagine now
another professional social media
platform being like, oh, we're we're now
starting up? It's like there's no room
for you, right? It's already done. That
that market is captured. And so, when
the there were other companies that were
competing for the same market, and the
people who were able to do raise the
most money, spend the most money the
fastest, attract the best talent were
able to capture it the fastest, then
sealing their competitive moat to
keeping that as a long-term cash cow
over the long haul. Which means that
those businesses lose a tremendous
amount of money for a short period of
time, and then they're able to kind of
get over the hump, and then become cash
machines. And so, for example, Amazon
was unprofitable for 9 years, famously.
And there's an interview of Jeff Bezos
getting a grilled on uh on The Tonight
Show, I think, with uh John Jay Leno. Is
it Jay Leno? Yeah. With Jay Leno. And
he's like, "You guys don't make any
money." And Jeff Bezos just gives it huh
huh huh huh huh.
He does this like weird laugh. Uh and
he's like, "Yeah, we don't, but we
could. We just choose not to because we
get better returns on our capital by
continuing to expand our um
our infrastructure so that we can
eventually support literally delivering
things the next day to every single
customer in America. Notwithstanding the
fact that they have the single most
successful subscription in history, in
Amazon Prime. More people are subscribed
to Amazon Prime than own a Bible. They
have over 300 million subscribers.
That's almost every single person in
America is subscribed to a digital
subscription for $99 per year, which I
think now is 135, to have the ability,
the privilege, of shopping on their
platform and getting faster shipping.
And so, when Bezos was making the
investment of capital into the business,
he asked the question, "Not what do I
think is going to change in the next 10
years?" He said, "What things won't
change in the next 10 years?" And so, he
realized that there are some
fundamentals that will never not be
true. People will always want things to
be faster.
People always will want things to be
easier.
risk-free. And if you can create an
outcome that is desirable, fast, easy,
and risk-free, then you have an
incredibly valuable business. And so,
this corresponds with
the value equation in the $100 Offers
book. And so, time delay is speed, ease
is going to be effort and sacrifice,
perceived likelihood of achievement is
your risk, and then the dream outcome is
making sure that you're not just making
things fast, easy, and risk-free that no
one wants. Right? And so, that's the
dream outcome component. And so, getting
things to your door, a lot of people
want that. If you can do it faster, they
like that more. If you can make it easy
for them, they like that even better.
And if you can make it so that the
purchase they had
is very likely to be good, aka the
entire review system that Amazon
pioneered. Reviews were not a thing.
Think about how crazy this is. They were
not a thing and a lot of people were
afraid and pushed against Bezos when he
wanted to roll out reviews because they
were afraid that sellers would hate it.
But he bet on the fact that customers
long-term would want the transparency.
So, in Jeff Bezos' very first capital
round that he raised, he sold 20% of the
business for $1 million to around 50
investors.
And so, imagine the return on that today
for that $1 million for 20% of Amazon.
It's more than he still controls to this
day for context. And he took that to buy
the initial inventory, get the website
established, hire the first developers
to get this going. And so, if you're
going to take on financial debt, use
other people's money into your business,
if you have a market that must be
captured quickly in order to get a
network effect of some sort, or you have
huge amounts of capital that are
required to make the business start to
begin with. So, if I wanted to start,
call it a a pharmaceutical business,
then I would probably have to have
capital for an extended period of time
to start a new drug, to do the research,
and then maybe 5 years after we get the
licensing, then have the ability to
print money. But that capital would have
to come from somewhere. And so, unless
you start as a billionaire to begin
with, which you absolutely could do
that, hypothetically, but the vast
majority of these businesses are not
started by billionaires, they're started
by everyday people who have a good idea,
and then they go to people who have
capital and say, "Hey, I'll give you a
piece of this upside." Now, this is the
uh
live fast, you know, die hard uh style
of making money. The reason it is that
way is because it will typically be very
investor favorable, uh especially the
earlier it is, because they're taking on
more risk. And so, the big thing about
these mega-wealthy paths is that the
underlying thing that occurs in all of
this is one, return on invested capital,
and two, the risk that you're taking in
order to validate or justify that
return. So, some guy in 1995 says he's
going to start a bookstore on the
internet, whatever that is, and you give
him a million dollars, it's like, I need
20% of this thing at least because no
one's ever done this before, you've
never started a business before, what's
the internet, and are people even going
to buy stuff on it, right? So, there are
so many unknowns here that it makes
sense that they had a tremendous amount
of compensation for the veritable
guarantee that they would lose the money
they were going to give. And that's
probably part of the reason that Jeff
Bezos didn't just raise it from his
friends and family despite the fact he
was a Wall Street and
insider. So, he could have easily gotten
the million dollars
from probably a handful of people, but
he also probably knew that there was a
very low chance of success, which I
think he says in his early interviews.
He figured that there was a low chance
of actually making this work. And so,
when you follow this path, the other
people's money into your business path,
there's really only two big kind of
potential outcomes. One is, as a
founder, you're going to de-risk along
the way, which means that sometimes
you'll get something called secondary.
So, when an investor puts money into a
business, they're going to appraise the
business based on how quickly it's
growing, how how likely it is to
continue to occur, and well, for them,
the ease of investment is high because
they just have to make the investment,
but the still the fundamental value
equation exists for them as investor
where your business is the product
itself. And so, let's say that we have a
business before the money that is worth,
we'll call it $10 million.
And then they say, I want to put $2
million into your business. So, if they
put $2 million into your business, this
business is now a $12 million business
where they now own 20%
and then everyone else now owns 80.
And so, the founders, the original
shareholders, are going to get diluted.
It means that they now own a smaller
percentage, but now the business has
more capital that can help it grow. Now,
a different path to this is if instead
of putting $2 million into the business,
they could have put, let's say, $1
million into the business and say,
"We're going to pay the founder over
here into his personal bank account $1
million."
And so, that's called secondary. And
then, most people don't even say
primary, but it's kind of almost assumed
that money's going into the business
when you're raising round a round of
funding. And so, some founders will
de-risk along the way because at some
point, you know, when you have a
billion-dollar asset and you have a
hundred thousand dollars in your bank
account, some investors will understand
that the founder themselves will become
a little bit volatile. And so, they want
to give them a little bit of money so
that they're not constantly freaking out
and actually can make better quality
decisions. So, it's not uncommon for
founders to take a little bit of chips
off the table as they continue to scale
and raise funding. Now, this is along
the way they're making this money, but
they still have this monster asset
that's worth billions of dollars or
hundreds of millions of dollars. And so,
there's basically two paths from there
for them to actually get paid. Path one
is that a big private equity firm, which
is now kind of a a new thing, is that
there are some firms that can buy
billion-dollar businesses and not have
them be public. This is a new thing of
probably the last call it 7 to 10 years
where there's enough private funds and
enough private money, sovereign wealth
sometimes overseas, uh that can take
down companies of this size. When I say
take down, I mean uh put the capital in
and buy it. So, a a simple example of
this would be like a company like
Kajabi, uh which is a uh a learning
platform
where Tiger Capital came in and uh
bought majority of the business and the
founders basically now a minority and
they kind of had a full exit and almost
all of that cash went to the founders
and very little into the business. And
so, in that setting, it's like they had
a lot of capital, they bought this
company, and so now they're, you know,
what's their exit? And so, most of these
paths, especially when you're raising
funding, most of the time is going to be
some IPO. So, an initial public offering
that then allows those shares to be made
public, which allows the person who owns
the whole pie and all the shareholders
to have liquidity. meaning they have
access that they can either sell those
shares or they can lend against those
shares. Either way, they have a way of
making money from the business, not
counting distributions, which many
businesses that are like this don't ever
give distributions because they continue
to reinvest the capital in the business
because the returns from reinvesting the
capital are superior to just getting a
dividend. And so, one of the
difficulties with raising money is the
nature of the money that you take on.
And so, all of these are completely
unique deals depending on the risk
profile of the company, the risk
appetite of the venture capital firm or
whoever is making the investment, and
how what their investment thesis or
philosophy is. And if you look at 100
different VCs, you'll have 100 different
investment philosophies in terms of what
they're thinking about. Now, all of them
just want a big company, of course, but
how they're going to get there is
different. So, there are some firms that
only take on one company in a specific
space, and they say, "We're going all in
on this company, and we're going to
provide all the help we possibly can to
help them grow." Right? There are some
companies that say, "We want exposure to
this entire market, and we're going to
take a bet on 10 different companies in
this market with the hopes that one of
them will win." So, they don't even care
that they're competitive. They're just
like, "We want to make sure that we're
with the winner whenever whoever the
winner is." And so,
if you're in the the latter example,
each of those VC checks may say, "Well,
we have to 10x this business in the next
2 years or it's going to massively lose
valuation." And so, they will force the
founders to take aggressive growth
measures that may sometimes be not in
the long-term benefit of A, the founder,
but B, the business. Which might mean
that they're overspending on
advertising, they're over-hiring on
talent, they're they let the culture,
uh, you know, get diluted or suffer
because they can't have enough filters
in place because of the rate or of the
pace of growth that they are requiring.
And a lot of this growth is almost
artificial because they're just
injecting so much cash into advertising
oftentimes to get the business to grow
that they actually didn't solve the core
fundamentals of the business. So, one of
the the dark sides of this that doesn't
get told is that as you do more and more
rounds, each VC or venture capitalist
often times gets a board seat or two
board seats. And all of a sudden you
might find out that you have a minority
of your business and you no longer have
voting power and you can get ousted from
your own business from the investors
that invested money in. And so a classic
example of this was Steve Jobs. There
was a period of time where he ended up
getting kicked out of Apple for years
before being able to come back. Now,
mind you at that point it was still
public company and it had a board of
directors, but it works the same way
with a private company. I have a good
friend of mine who has a
uh uh who who exited had a had enough of
an exit. It was a billion-dollar
valuation. He didn't get a billion
dollars, but he had enough of an exit
that he could retire and uh he continued
to work, but then they just said, "We
don't want you to work here anymore."
And so he got fired. And then 3 years
later they asked him to come back. And
so it's very common to think, "Oh, this
founder doesn't really know what he's
doing." But the thing is the founder
always knows the heart and the pulse of
the business cuz you're the one who
knows each of the problems and why
everything exist the way it does. In
terms of wealth creation, when you take,
let's say, 100 of these bets, you can
get supremely wealthy. So, believe it or
not, uh venture capital is the highest
returning asset class of all asset
classes. The problem is the amount of
capital that you can allocate into that
asset class typically is very closed or
very small because most of these funds
and good companies are oversubscribed.
There's many investors who want to put
money in when these deals are really
good or the likely that the business
succeeds feels really high. And so what
happens is uh you may take 100 bets and
the winner you have may offset the
losses, but you're still never going to
get richer than the guy who's has a
fully concentrated bet on the one
business. And so there's 99
entrepreneurs who failed and didn't make
money, but one of them who still gets
even richer than the venture capital
investors who put who put money in. They
use that one winner to offset their
losses, whereas if you were the only guy
who went all in on that, you don't have
losses to offset. You just went all in.
And the reason you would take path one
is because you have a business model
that requires you to grow quickly or
have tremendous amount of capital for an
extended period of time before it could
become profitable. And using other
people's capital, rather than saving up,
let's say 10 lifetimes worth of earnings
to start a pharmaceutical company, uh
makes
sense. If you've ever heard of like XYZ
company raises money at a $500 million
valuation, they're not saying they sold
the company for $500 million, they're
saying that the founders diluted
themselves and the other investors by
some percentage, and it could be as
little as 1 or 2%. Um at that valuation.
So, for example, if you had a $500
million company, uh and you sold 2% of
that business, then you would have $10
million in cash that you could then put
inside of the business to then help it
grow. But, you'd only sell 2% for that
at that valuation. And so, hopefully
this puts some uh relative numbers to
some things that you've heard before.
So, let's say that you don't want all
that risk. I guess we're going green
now.
Uh you have your money
and your
business.
And so, this is probably the most common
path that entrepreneurs take, and I will
say that a lot of the entrepreneurs that
I aspire to and like to model tend to
fall in this bucket.
Now, within this model, I want to make a
very big point clear, which is that many
people who are bootstrapped or could
otherwise be bootstrap businesses, as in
the founder themselves funds everything
and doesn't take outside money, they
sometimes act as though they are
venture-backed and that they must grow
at all cost.
And they chase growth for the sake of
growth.
And my first big thing that I will share
with you is that rush is imaginary. 99%
of businesses don't need to have some
aggressive growth timeline. Because
whether you're starting a chicken shack
or you're starting a lawn care business,
there's no network effect that you're
going to build up. You just have to keep
outcompeting and doing a good job in the
local area or in the service vertical
that you're concentrated in in order to
achieve good returns for the business.
And so, if you look at Chick-fil-A with
S. Truett Cathy, they had a competitor
at earlier on in their career called
Boston Market. Some of the older people
in my audience might have remembered
this. I used to go there after baseball
games. Um and Boston Market was kind of
like chicken and home-style cooking, and
they were direct competitor with
Chick-fil-A. Now, they raised a
gazillion dollars and went super super
fast, and everyone told Chick-fil-A that
they should do the same thing. But S.
Truett Cathy being a lot more prudent of
a man who was not who didn't want to
take that kind of debt on, who didn't
want to just chase some imaginary um
title for ego, he said, "We just need to
get better, and if we get better, our
customers will demand that we get
bigger."
And fast forward 10 years after Boston
Market was, you know, kicking the tail
off them and was a a Wall Street
darling, they eventually went bankrupt.
Meanwhile, Chick-fil-A, 75 years later,
has 2,600 locations, and they're all
privately held, and they have no debt.
And so, now you might think, "Well, I
don't want to wait 75 years." It really
depends on what kind of vision you have
as an entrepreneur because, you know,
for me, my belief is like, if I could
build something that outlasts me, I
think that would be amazing. Um and
sometimes the way to build something for
the long term is to not build it for the
short term, which is not fast and
growing at all cost because sometimes
you grow bigger by giving yourself the
time to grow longer.
Yeah, and I share the story because this
is how I've started every company
that I founded.
So, I haven't founded a company and
taken on capital. I have invested and
co-founded, um but I if I'm if I'm the
sole founder of the business, I have
typically bootstrapped it, meaning I I
funded the original business. So, when I
had my my online uh fitness business was
my very first business, uh that was just
me, and I spent the $5,000 to start that
up. Um my
gym cost me uh I think $37,000 in total
to start my first gym and sign the lease
and get it kind of outfitted. Um so,
that was on me that fronted that
capital. And when I even opened up each
additional location, it was the same
thing. And there's a key point there
that I'm going to talk about return on
invested capital in a second, so
stay tuned. Um the the next thing I had
was GymLaunch, which was started by me,
Prestige Labs started by me, Allen
started by me, acquisition.com started
by me, and funded. And so, when you do
that, you don't have any dilution, but
you also have complete control. And so,
if you can think long, you can grow big.
Now, back to the return on invested
capital. Every business, you want to
have a compounding vehicle within it.
So, what I want to do is walk you
through uh
a little company example that will
illustrate this.
So, let's say we have company A and we
have company B. And let's say this is
year one, year two, and year three. All
right? So, let's say year one, company A
sells 100 customers, company B sells 100
customers.
Next year, for company A, they lose 100,
but then they sell 200 customers. So,
they're plus 200 and then minus 100.
Right? Uh
yes. So, like they lost 100% of those
customers, they still did 200 sales,
okay? This company gets plus 100 and
then minus zero. So, they're now at 200
in total. 100 from the first year, 100
new customers from the second year.
And let's say year three,
company A sells 300 new customers and
now also loses the 200 customers from
the year before. And year three, they uh
company B sells another 100 customers,
but has the 100 from year one and the
100 from year two. Now, both of these
companies are going to have 300
customers in that year.
Which business would you rather have?
Hopefully, if you watch anything that I
talk about, you would want company B.
Why? Because this is a company that is
stable, that will continue to grow year
over year over year, and they don't need
to necessarily grow They don't need to
grow faster. If they just do a good job
and keep the customers they have, they
will just consistently grow year over
year. And I'll tell you this, knowing
that no matter what happens, you will
always get bigger is a very nice value
proposition for an investor or for you
as an entrepreneur. And so, the key is
that you want to have some sort of
compounding vehicle within the business.
And so, to accomplish that, there are
pretty much only two ways to do this.
So, the first is that you sell stuff
that people never stop buying. And so,
that can either be a recurring or
reoccurring membership. So, a
reoccurring business might be something
like Coca-Cola, right? Where you start
drinking Coca-Cola and you go to Costco
and you buy it. When you go to
restaurants, you buy it. And so, you buy
from a number of different places. Now,
you're not on a subscription for
Coca-Cola, but you might just buy it on
a regular basis. And so, because of
that, once they acquire you as a
customer, you keep paying them.
Starbucks is the same way. Once someone
goes to Starbucks, the average customer
spends $14,000 at Starbucks. They just
keep buying products from them, right?
You're not on a subscription, but you do
keep going back. The other version of
this is something like Netflix, where
you have a subscription, you have a
membership of some sort, and people stay
on and keep paying.
And so, in either of those situations,
as you acquire customers, the business
just keeps growing. And so, every new
customer you bring in just grows this
big bolus of people that over time makes
you more and more money.
Now, the second scenario is where uh and
I this happens all the time in like home
services, uh solar, you know, roofing,
uh a lot of a lot of real estate
adjacent type stuff, uh where you have a
business I mean, even physical products
can be this way, um where you have a
product that doesn't have a lot of
return business. So, if you buy a house
and sell a house, it's like maybe
somebody comes back to you 3 4 years
later. There's nothing wrong with that,
but you probably wouldn't describe that
as a recurring or reoccurring business.
And so, instead, if you owned a business
like that, what you'd want is a growing
network of people who never stop selling
for you. So, here you have customers who
never stop buying, and here you have a
distribution base of people who never
stop selling. And so, for example,
Prestige Labs, the supplement company we
had, um
people who go to the gym and try to lose
weight, that's a very cyclical thing.
People try and lose weight for a little
bit, and then they fall off, um and
that's common. Now, that being said,
what can make the company more stable is
if I have a thousand locations that are
consistently selling product every
month. Now, the who they sell it to
might change, but the fact that they are
continuously selling becomes the node of
kind of recurring revenue or reoccurring
revenue, but just one level chunked up.
And so, this is a distribution-based
model, this is a customer-based model,
but both of these compound. And so, when
I look to invest in a business or start
a business, I try and solve for this.
Once you solve for this, growth becomes
inevitable. Right? And because of this,
when I was 26 or 7 years old, was the
first year that I made like a lot of lot
of money, and I took home um I think
just under $17 million profit
personally. Uh in income. And so, um
this stuff absolutely does work. Uh so,
this isn't just like armchair theory
that I'm just like talking about
something I haven't done. Um
which I can understand any skepticism
around that. Um because of a YouTube
video on the internet. That being said,
the key to growth in this path, so when
we're at
So, when you're in this box, it's your
business and your money, your key or
your path to growth is something called
return on invested capital. So, it's
ROIC.
Now, return on invested capital
basically is how much money does it cost
me to make more money? And so, for
example, there are multiple levels of
this within a business. And so, if I
have a brick-and-mortar business, you're
going to have the lowest level of this,
which would be LTV, lifetime value, to
CAC, which is how much does it cost me
to get a customer versus how much do I
make from that customer over time.
Right? That's the base unit of economic
arbitrage in a business. This is how you
make money fundamentally. Now, level up
from this, you have ROIC, which still
talks about the same concept, return on
invested capital. How much does it cost
me, the return, this is basically the
LTV, capital is the cost. Right? It's
just one frame. So, I'm trying to give
you the the real terms rather than just
use some of the
third-grade third-grade terminology so
that you can actually learn it. All
right. So, return on invested capital
typically will describe the larger unit.
So, if my my my massage business, for
example, cost me $10 to get a customer
worth $1,000, then that would be an
amazing LTV to CAC. But the question is
how much does it cost me to open a
massage studio? Well, I might I mean
this doesn't take into account the
lobby, the build out, the licenses, the
recruiting costs, administrative costs,
tech costs,
um you know, construction, whatever,
right? And so, at this point, it's like,
okay, maybe I have amazing LTV to CAC,
but my return on capital might be not as
good, or it might be amazing, right? And
so, here is basically the bigger money
multiplier within the business over the
longer term.
And so, let's say that we have a
business that does $1 million top line,
and we own the whole thing, okay?
Million dollars top line, and let's say
it makes $250,000
in profit. Okay.
Now,
if we are entrepreneurs, then we have
two options.
We can reinvest that in our business, or
we can put it into another business, or
another asset. But if we know that our
returns on invested capital are very
good, then it would behoove us to put it
into our own business. And so, let's say
that my return on invested capital in my
brick-and-mortar chain, for example, is
that I uh
um let's say that it costs me to open
this million-dollar business, it costs
me 50 50,000 dollars.
It's an S. $50,000 to open a store, and
within 12 months, it makes $250,000
back. And if you hear that, you're like,
"Whoa, that's amazing." This happens all
the time. This is not that uncommon. I
mean, I told you about my gym cost me
37,000, and I was making 20,000 a month
within 6 months. And so, uh you
absolutely can have these kind of uh
these metrics, okay? So, at this point,
what would it make sense for me? Well, I
should probably take my 250, and
basically have this times five, and then
this gives me this times five, and all
of a sudden, the next year, I make 1.250
million.
And what do I do the next year?
This is how compounding occurs. So, then
I I split this up, and what would this
allow me to do? I would open up 25
locations, and then that would
make me 5.25
million
in net income, right? Now, of course,
when you're at this point, the
constraint will quickly be operational
constraint. You'll actually have a
people issue of trying to staff all
these things, get all the locations
signed. Um and this is why some people
turn to franchising and things like that
so that they can expand a little faster.
And that being said, it is the most
expensive form of equity because you're
giving away basically the entirety of
your business for a percentage of the
top line, but then you have to still
service all of the locations almost as
if you own them. And so, I'm not the
biggest fan of franchising. There are
times where it does make the most sense,
but most times it's because founders are
in a rush. And so, if it's your first
business ever, my strong recommendation
is that you start here because you have
to pay down so much ignorance debt, so
much so much tax from the universe for
not knowing what you're doing that the
last thing you really want to do is risk
the money of your friends and family.
That's just my two cents. You can do
whatever you want. Um that is my
opinion. If this is your first time
business,
I would strongly recommend doing your
business uh with your money because
there's so many things that you don't
know and you have to pay down your
ignorance debt. You have to pay down the
cost of not knowing what you're doing,
and I'd rather you do that on your money
than someone else's.
Now,
if you do start to have this business
that starts doing well and you start
having this XX cash, our $250,000 in the
example I just gave, let's just do a
different color to keep things keep
things zesty. So, the third path is that
you can have your money
with
other people's businesses.
So, remember here we had our $250,000 in
profit from this business that we
created. Well, of course, we could put
it into our own, but if we put it into
someone else's,
then we want to understand what our
return profile is going to be. And so,
this is what I would consider the path
of the investor. And so, if the first,
you know, category is the path of kind
of like the venture-backed entrepreneur,
the second path is the bootstrapped
entrepreneur, the third path is the path
of the retail uh or just traditional
investor. You have some extra cash and
you want to put it into something else.
So, for example, you guys have probably
seen the show Shark Tank where there's
five sharks that are all wealthy people
and entrepreneurs come to them and they
invest in their companies. Now, what
they get what they get what they give is
money and help and what they get back is
some percentage of the upside depending
on how the deal is structured.
And so, those sharks tend to have less
time and so what they're compensated for
is risk.
And so, when you become an investor,
your chief form the the chief thing that
you give is that you de-risk the founder
and you incur some of that risk, you
shoulder some of that risk, not in
exchange for work or time, but in
exchange for capital, which
fundamentally means I took time
somewhere else, I did work somewhere
else, and I'm going to throw that into
your business
so that I can offset your personal risk.
Now, the benefit of investor is that you
can diversify to a wide degree, meaning
you can take 100 bets, you can take
1,000 bets. So, every single share that
you own in a publicly traded company is
a small bet that you're making as an
investor. And every share that you own
of a
privately traded company works the same
way. It's obviously not privately
traded, but just off market, it works
the same way. Now, investors in general
tend not to be the wealthiest people in
the world. And so, this is why in my
opinion, real estate has created more
millionaires than any other vehicle, but
private equity has created more
billionaires than any other vehicle.
And so, it's because of the nature of
the concentration of risk and reward.
And so, when you are
when you are the business that goes all
the way, to the investor, you might
represent 1% of their portfolio. So, you
might have a they might have a huge win
with this business, but it's only going
to be 1%. But if it's your business in
either of these scenarios, then you're
probably going to have a big slice of
that pie, which means that their 1% win
might be a 20% win, an 80% win for you.
But what we don't see is the other 99
entrepreneurs who just go to zero. And
so this is where I think that from a
personal level you have to know what you
are shooting for. Because if you're
like, I just want to get rich, then
investing in sound assets that can give
you a good return over a long period of
time, there's probably no surer way to
become wealthy. To become the richest
person in the world or the top 100
richest people in the world, you will
almost invariably have to do one of the
other two paths that I just described.
The fourth path that I'll show you last
is one that also gets you on the top 100
list, too. And I'll share how that works
in a second. But the beauty of being a
traditional investor where you take your
cash and you invest in businesses is
that it's unlimited in its scalability.
It's for the most part passive, with the
exception of the active work that you
have to do in finding, sourcing,
negotiating the deals, which is work. Uh
but typically less than running a
business. Um and so since I am an active
investor, why don't I share with you
some of the things that I look for in
businesses that I invest in. Now, to be
clear, this will be my investment
thesis. There are many. So for me, I
create content like this so that I can
get exposure to entrepreneurs so that
they can come towards acquisition.com
and say, "Hey, I'd like to do a deal
with you." Or I'd like your help to help
us scale. And we happily do that. And
this is how we get to know businesses at
early stages so that we can be with them
throughout their careers. I mean, the
smallest company that we that we started
working with had done $2 million the
year before, and this year we'll
probably finish around 110 million in
revenue. And that's, mind you, over
years, not like a couple months. All
right? And so number one is that I try
to invest in uh high cash flow
businesses that are profitable. So I
like getting distributions every month
because it offsets my principal, and it
tells me that the business is doing well
uh very on a much faster feedback loop.
So number one is I invest in high cash
flow
businesses.
And mind you, this is in my active arm
at acquisition.com, which is kind of our
private equity portfolio. We have a
venture arm, which is ACQ Ventures,
uh where we write smaller checks for
smaller slices of businesses where we
are not involved and our primary
value add is risk and a light amount of
help compared to what we do when we're
heavily, you know, investing in a
company where we're taking, you know,
30, 40, 50, you know, plus percent of
the business.
In those instances, we're going to be
working, we're going to be recruiting,
we're going to be work you know, we're
going to be leading the the strategy
that business versus just saying, "I
believe in this entrepreneur and this
team. I believe in this concept and I'm
willing to write write a check and take
on some risks I can get exposed to some
upside."
So, this is my private equity thesis.
The second is that I want something that
can grow.
And so, fundamentally, for growth,
there's only two ways that a business
can grow, right? We can increase the
number of customers
or we can increase lifetime gross profit
or LTV per customer. So, we can get more
people or increase how much they're
worth. And if we see a path that's very
clear that we can say, "Oh, we know how
we're going to get this company more
customers or we know how we're going to
be able to double, triple, quadruple how
much customers are worth," which one
will immediately make us more money, but
then also allows to spend more money to
get more customers. So, School, for
example, is uh one of our largest
investments. At this point, um
I wanted to take a very big swing on
something that I think could change an
industry and it's an industry that I
understand very well,
uh which is education and media. And I
feel like very I have edge there. I
understand it. Now, could something
happen it could go wrong? Maybe, but in
the last year, we, you know, 6x'd uh the
business, so it did uh we had a good
year. Uh
and so, with School, it was like, "Okay,
do I clearly know uh how we could help
it get more customers?" Yes. And so,
that was fundamentally what we drove.
Now, the lifetime gross profit is very
much product driven, which is not the
role that we decided to take on for this
particular investment.
But, I did know that I have a huge part
of my audience that wants to start a
business. And so, I said, "Okay, well, I
don't have something for people who want
to start a business. All my stuff is
really for business owners. But, people
who want to start businesses still want
to learn about business before they
start businesses." And so, I wanted
somewhere I could say, "Well, if you're
not sure,
go there. And if you're not even sure
about that, just read some of these
books so you can get a little bit more
context on what you could potentially
sell." The third thing that I look for
is focus. And I talk about this a lot,
which is is the founder someone who can
say no, who is focused on a specific
avatar, a specific customer, has lived
the life or the problem of that
customer, and I don't want to have to
niche slap a founder. All right, so
niche slap is where they're like, "I
sir, I do everything for everyone,"
which really means nothing for no one.
And so, the benefit of being very
focused on one specific customer avatar
or ICP, ideal customer profile,
depending on what market you listen to.
Uh
if you have that, you can solve people's
problems far better because you can be
more nuanced in the solutions you
provide. You can also charge more
because the actual value is higher. And
you can tend to acquire customers
cheaper because your messaging will be
more targeted, and the target of your
advertising itself can also be more
targeted. So, both the words, the offer,
the deliverable, the pricing, all of
this is a strategic question, which is
why I want to make sure the strategy of
the business makes sense.
And then fourth, and this is probably
the biggest one of all of them if we're
being very real,
is jockey
over everything.
Now,
I'll put one caveat out, which is I'm
not going to try and enter a market that
I think is going to die. So, if
someone's like, "Hey, I have a new
gas-powered car," that probably wouldn't
be the bet that I would make. If someone
says, "Hey, I have this brand new print
newspaper that I want to start,"
probably wouldn't be the bet that I
would make. But, if they're in a market
that I don't foresee is going to
disappear tomorrow, then all of my
emphasis going to be on the jockey,
which is how good is the person, the
founding team, um for the business.
Because the The is is that the founding
team is going to encounter innumerable
problems as they try and scale this
thing and you have to trust their
ability to solve problems cuz it doesn't
matter how good the idea is, your
ability to consistently solve problems
in a cash efficient manner is how you
can grow a business over the long term.
And so you want someone and I I'll use
Uncle Warren's, you know, three three
big three big values is you want someone
who's incredibly industrious and
hardworking. You want someone who has
very strong ethics and someone who's
competent and intelligent, right? And so
you have competence, you have work ethic
and you have integrity. And so he
famously says, well, you know, if if you
have just competence and work ethic but
you don't have integrity, you've got a
crook who's working really hard against
you. He's like very bad. He said, so if
you are going to have that, you'd rather
have somebody who's really competent but
lazy and disintegrous because at least
that way he's not going to do you as
much damage, right? So you want to have
all three. Now what's difficult about
this is that even one of those three
things is hard to find. Somebody who
truly has character even when the chips
are stacked against them because that's
the only time that it matters. Or
someone who has tremendous work ethic
especially especially when it matters
most in the business. When when things
are tough or you're going through a
growth period that's just like it's just
requiring you to work 20 hours a day
because you just you just there's
there's not enough people but you need
the business requires it right now. Or
you just have someone who's exceptional
product or prospect knowledge that they
that intergually gives them that gives
them tremendous edge over their
competition because they
they understand everything down to I
love this analogy that a VC who invested
in Regal, which is now you know, in a
pretty tough situation but for years was
a a cash cow business, Regal Cinemas.
He said when he talked to the founder,
he said that guy understood the cost
everything down to the kernel of
popcorn. He said he just knew everything
about the business. He said he's like
and there was really no reason that I
should get into cinemas. He's like, but
when I saw this guy talk about it, he
was like he was so energetic and so
passionate about it and clearly had good
character and he just understood the
business so well. He was like there's no
way with this guy's not going to make
money in it. And he did.
And that And that is a great example of
a business that required a ton of
capital to start. Opening up movie
theaters costs a ton of capital. And so,
it makes sense that that business owner,
even though he knew everything about it,
probably been there for a long time, he
still asked for investors rather than
saying, "You know what? I'm going to
take another 10 years to save all the
money on my own just to start one." When
he's like, "You know what? I could
leverage other people's lifetimes of
work so that I could basically be at
year 10 at year one and have a smaller
slice of a much bigger pie." And so,
fundamentally, betting on the jockey is
the is the highest leverage bet you can
make because you're betting on someone's
ability to solve problems in a dynamic
environment. And businesses, if
anything, it is dynamic. So, the
environment might change, the market may
shift, uh some of the variables or
assumptions that you thought were going
to be there aren't. And some of the most
famous founders were companies that
started not even with that intention.
Like Slack was a video game uh
uh company that eventually just had this
engineering Slack thing or Slack thing,
right? This engineering messaging tool
that ended up being good, and then they
shifted to that, right? Because they
just had exceptional founders who were
able to pivot and be adaptable. And so,
in some ways, betting on the right
jockey is almost like insurance for an
investor. It's like, I just think this
guy is brilliant and hardworking, and I
think when something happens, he will
figure it out. And so, when we're
looking at all four of these things,
it's like high cash flow business, it
has high growth potential, there's a
focused founder, and they they they they
exhibit high character, high work ethic,
and high competence, then it's like,
"Okay, well, if there's companies that
meet all of these criteria, which is
still rare, what makes you pick one
versus another?" And so, for us, we
operate under at acquisition.com, uh one
thesis, which is the theory of
constraints, which is that a system will
grow until it is constrained and then it
will grow no further. And so, once we
find what the constraint of the business
is, then we attack that constraint with
all the resources and all the brain
power and all the money we have to try
and solve that constraint to then unlock
the next level of growth until the next
constraint. And so, to give a simple
example, if we were to simply 10x
advertising for uh you know, a lawn care
business, if they don't have 10 times
the sales people to take those leads,
The next constraint like us just blowing
the doors off the front end is just
going to lead to the next constraint.
Then we have to hire more sales guys.
But even if we did the marketing and
then we did the sales, then we'd have to
hire more guys to do the the to mow the
lawns, right? And so the constraint will
continue to move down the the pipeline
until the entire business is the
constraint and then you will realize the
throughput increase of having this
huge influx.
And so for us, if we understand the
business well, so it has all of these
things and it happens to be in a space
that we feel like we understand better
than other people, then that's where we
will be more likely to take our bet. And
the better we understand it, the bigger
the bet we'll make. And so to give you
context on this, the company founders
within our portfolio uh not including
school because this metric would be
stupid if I put school in there. Uh
the average founder in our private
equity portfolio has had a 13x return on
equity. And so think about it like this.
If your company was worth
$10 million when it started,
when it started, your slice, I'd have to
the the circle would be much bigger than
this page, your slice of equity, let's
just not draw into size, right? Your
slice of equity later would be worth 130
million.
And that's at the point right now today
of making this video. And so uh
independent of how much they quote sold
to us, they are significantly wealthier
than they were before. And I think we
may be the only private equity fund that
even tracks what the return on founder
equity is. And that's because long-term
I believe that me getting great deal
flow from founders who want to do
business with me is the long-term
strategy that is going to make
acquisition.com into a powerhouse um
with a new model of private equity. As
an investor, you can think through these
things and invest in companies that meet
these requirements and ideally are in
companies that you have some sort of
edge in that you understand better than
other people. The final way of getting
ultra wealthy is other people's money
dot dot dot dot dot and other people's
businesses.
You're like, wait a second. Okay, so
we've got other people's money in your
business, that's raising funding. You've
got your money in your business, that's
bootstrapping it. You've got your money
in other people's business, you're an
investor. And then you've got other
people's money and other people's
businesses, which makes you a fund
manager. So, let me explain.
For example,
when I sold Gym Launch and Prestige
Labs, I sold those to American Pacific
Group in 2021.
They are a $500 fund, which now has a
second fund that's another 700, so they
they have $1.2 billion under management.
Now, they bought Gym Launch and Prestige
Labs together as a package for $46.2
million.
Now, that check they did to me
represented a small amount of the
overall funds that they had. And so, let
me show you exactly why people who run
funds make a huge amount of money.
So, a typical fund manager, typically,
not always, but it is common for, if you
wanted to raise call it $100 million,
okay? Let's say that that's the amount
of funding that you wanted to raise.
A fund manager, which would then be
typically the general partner, the GP,
would put something like 5% in. So, they
would contribute $5 million of their own
capital, and sometimes it's between
multiple partners, to fund the 100
million. Cuz most investors want to make
sure that you have some skin in the
game, that you care. All right? Now,
that means that they're going to get $95
million
from other people's money. Okay?
Stay on track with me.
Now, the question is, what does $100
million buy me?
Well, in private equity, $100 million
can then lever, so you can leverage
this,
and get $200 million in debt to buy $300
million worth of businesses.
So, think about the leverage here. You
put $5 million in, and you're able to
buy $300 million worth of businesses.
So, then the question is, okay, but then
what do these guys get for taking this
risk? Great question. So, the typical
fund structure is something has a has a
two and 20 structure. This is kind of
industry average. There's obviously some
that are different than that, but this
is the most common structure. And so, 2%
the first number that people say it's
like what's the structure? If you hear
someone say two and 20, one in one in
25, whatever. What they're referencing
is the management fee, which is charged
off of funds raised every year.
And then the 20% is off of the profit
that's generated at the ultimate
conclusion of the fund. All right, so
let's say 10 years from now we've exited
all of the positions that we had and we
turned this $300 of companies into $900.
So, over 10 years let's say we tripled
the money in general. We tripled the
tripled the the value of the companies.
Okay? Now, well what do we have to do?
Well, over let's say this is 10 years.
Over the 10 years that 2% equals So,
this is management fee.
Equals $20 for that 10 year period of
time. So, you get $20 of management fees
just for that 10 year period of time.
Now mind you, you have employees, you
have costs, and so fundamentally the
management fees are supposed to help you
run the actual fund without having to
put more stress on the companies that
you're buying. The 20% so this is called
the carry. What's cool about this is
that there's no tax with uh carried
interest. Sorry. The cool
cool thing with carried interest, which
is kind of the the profit part for the
fund manager, is that it gets taxed like
capital gains. And so, basically
they can make their income in a tax
efficient manner.
So, let's say that we sell our
all the companies and so we have to take
out the debt that we owe, right? So, we
have $200 of debt that we owe and then
we have to return the 100 I'm just going
to say round numbers. We have to put the
$100 back into the investors' pockets.
All right, so we have $600 back. Now,
there's going to be some interest costs
here so maybe it's maybe it's uh you
know
if it was over a 10 year period we'll
say $100 in uh in interest payments that
we had to pay uh to also carry this
debt. Okay? Let's just say
hypothetically. All right, so we've got
$500 million left over. Now, we have our
20% carry.
Which means that we're going to get $100
million
for
for doing this.
So, we took our five.
We got paid 20
and 100 in that 10 year period.
And this 100 also post-tax
is $80 million.
And so, all in all
you're making $100 million plus
with a $5 million slug.
And so, mind you, this is when you start
with $5 million.
What happens when you capitalize a fund
and you put $100 million in and you
raise a $2 billion fund?
Well, just multiply these numbers by 20.
It gets really big really fast. And so,
fund managers employ uh one of the key
principles of wealth, and I'll have a
follow-up video on the on the on the
principles of wealth. But one of the key
principles is leverage. And so, they
have multiple forms of leverage that
they're able to multiply. It's why
acquisition.com is two like, in my
opinion, the two strongest forces in
business are leverage and supply and
demand.
And so, supply and demand is this these
two little curves here, and then
leverage here is this fulcrum. All
right? And so, they first leverage their
$5 million to get $95 million from
investors. Then they leverage the
entirety of that $100 million
to buy companies, which then they use
the companies they leverage the
companies to get the debt
off of these initial cash checks that
they can write.
And then all of a sudden that five
becomes 60 times bigger in terms of the
assets that you can control.
And so,
obviously APG ran this exact model, and
they had a $500 million fund. Right?
Um
but
if acquisition.com one day in the future
wanted to have a fund saying, "Hey, uh
I'll put money in and if you guys want
access to deals that I have access to
and want my team to work on for you,
basically, then we would have some fun
structure in place that would allow
everyone else to participate.
And so, a fund typically should get
structured because you have one of two
key things, in my opinion. This is now
just me talking Alex's opinion.
You should have access to deal flow that
other people don't have, so proprietary
deal flow. The reason proprietary deal
flow is super valuable is two things.
Number one is that you will get better
negotiated terms on the deals, meaning
that you could buy assets for maybe less
than intrinsic value or less than a
competitive process might yield, right?
Like if you're in an auction, you will
pay more than if you're just making a
one-on-one deal, which is why when you
sell a house, you're like, "I hope a lot
of people bid," right? That's really
good if you're a seller, really bad if
you're a buyer, right? And so, you want
to have deals that you can just be the
only person bidding on it. So, that's
thing one. So, so for example, what that
looks like is
for acquisition.com, it'd be businesses
that are applying on the site at
acquisition.com saying, "Yes, I'd be
interested in selling a business. I'd
like you guys to help me, you know, help
invest in the business to help it
scale." That's what that would be. Now,
the reason that it's proprietary is
they're not typically going to other
people. They're not saying, "I want
investment. I'm going to pick
acquisition.com of 10 people." They're
saying, "I want to work with Alex and
his team."
Right? Because of their proven track
record.
The second thing that you want, in my
opinion,
as investment thesis, is some sort of
edge. You want some sort of insider
knowledge, not insider trading, to be
clear. Insider knowledge on the industry
or prospect that a company serves. And
so, you will find that there are some
private equity firms, for example, that
just specialize in manufacturing.
They're just really good in in heavy
manufacturing businesses. Some private
equity firms are really good at CPG, so
consumer packaged goods, direct to
consumer, physical products e-commerce,
right? There's there's whole whole
fields of great private equity firms
around that. And they typically have
founders or ex-founders who funded that
with their own exits, and then basically
redo the playbook with more leverage.
Um there are some funds that just
specialize in software, right? There are
some funds that just specialize in
professional services. There are funds
media. And so, uh you want both
proprietary deal flow, so that you have
deals that no one else has access to.
These are off-market deals, right? That
they only want to do business with you,
so you can get better, more attractive
prices and terms. And then you want to
have a way to accelerate value. So, if
you want to think about investing as a
business, right? We have LTV to CAC,
too. These things are not uh the these
things completely apply to investing
business. So, the CAC is if I have
proprietary deal flow, then I'm going to
be able to acquire customers, or acquire
deals, for lower prices, and on better
terms. And if I have a way to grow those
businesses, then I will have higher
lifetime deal value than somebody who
doesn't. And so, when you combine those
two things, you get better returns. So,
you have more value on the buy, and more
exit value on the sale, and that
discrepancy is what creates the outsized
alpha, which beats the market. And so,
fundamentally, this is what This has
been my thesis for acquisition.com. Now,
I haven't talked about this as much
publicly, mostly because it applies to
fewer people than the vast majority of
my content, but our team decided, "You
know what? Let's Let's talk about what
we do." And so, so within the private
investing world, the fund world, there's
typically kind of two big buckets.
You've got private equity,
which means that they are buying
equities that are private or off-market,
which is about a 60- or 70-year-old
industry. And then you've got VC, or
venture capital.
And within venture capital, you have
growth funds, you have seed stage funds,
you have Series A, Series B. And these
will typically be defined by their check
size.
Now, an An tidbit for you is I was
talking to David Weisburd who runs 10X
Capital
unaffiliated with Cardone.
He just actually owns 10X Capital, kind
of funny.
And they
he exclusively talks to LPs. So, big
endowments that have many, many, many,
many billions of dollars and that's like
his entire network. Good podcast if you
want to check it out if you like really
like high high-level investing. And so,
they did a meta-study and they found out
that VC or venture capital assets, so
think
software companies in general, have the
highest return of any asset class. They
average about 14% per year, which is
I think the second highest one is REITs,
so real estate investment trusts. I
think average like about 12% a year.
And then you've got, you know, the
public public securities, so normal
stocks is something like nine and
change. And then you can of go down the
the gamut of different asset classes.
Now, mind you, this is just the class of
assets. Not just a specific stock.
Obviously, in every one of those
categories there's some, you know, real
estate buildings that have, you know,
100X and there's probably not 100X, but
have gone up a lot. There's software
companies that have definitely 100Xed.
And even individual stocks that are not
software that have also 100Xed, right?
Tesla, for example. And most of these
still follow that kind of two and 20
structure. There are some, like there's
a there's a famous one that's zero and
35. So, like it's really about how you
want to shift risk with the founders.
Sorry, shift risk with your limited
partners. To give you context, private
equity tends to manage tends to manage
bigger amounts of money. So, if you look
at Blackstone has about a trillion
dollars of assets under management.
Apollo has about 600 billion
under management. KKR has has 500
billion dollars under management. So,
monstrous sums of money. And there's a
reason
why
private equity has created some of the
wealthiest people in the world. The fund
managers of these groups are all deca,
you know, deca-billionaires and above.
So, even Schwarzman I think is at 40-ish
billion, just an absurd amount of money.
And they do that because of all the
leverage that I explained earlier. Now,
venture capital tends to, not always,
but tends to. So, if you have like A16Z,
which is Andreessen Horowitz, has about
$50 billion under management. Sequoia,
one of the most well-known
funds in the world, has about $56
billion. So, they're about the same in
terms of size. So, you can notice
there's an order of magnitude difference
in terms of the size, but they're
usually making bets on what the next
Facebook is going to be. Whereas these
guys tend to buy more traditional
businesses that are already monstrous.
And they do a little bit more of the
financial arbitrage, meaning they're
it's more about how they can buy it at
one price, sell it at another price, or
combine assets in a way that makes it
accretive. So, it's a fancy word for
just value additive to the overall
enterprise value. Whereas these guys
tend to do zero mergers and acquisitions
and bet on the organic or viral growth
of the companies that they take shares
in. And so, these guys typically focus
on inorganic growth. And these guys
focus on organic growth, meaning the
company itself grows. And these tend to
grow by globbing in multiple things
together to make the overall entity
bigger. And so, that's where like, for
example, if I were to buy an auto repair
shop, I might be able to buy the auto
repair shop at a five times multiple and
then get debt for half of that. So, I
put two and a half times
their their income into the deal and
then buy five other ones with that and
then all together sell them for 10. And
I can triple my money in that period of
time without actually having grown any
of the companies.
That's where it gets wild. Now,
in this game, all they want to do is see
this company just keep hockey sticking.
Now, if you're like, "Okay, well, where
does acquisition.com sit within this
world?" So, we kind of sit in the
middle. So, obviously we have ACQ
Ventures, which is just traditional VC,
but our actual private equity side, we
do little M&A.
Like we do if it's if it makes sense and
typically it's because it's like an
adjacent purchase of a business that
we're referring a lot of business over
to, and it makes sense for us to just
kind of bring them in, more than we're
like actively seeking out 10 follow-on
investments to glob together. So, we do
less financial arbitrage and more value
add in terms of our ability to help
businesses scale. And for us, that's
less capital intensive, and I would
rather This is me personally. It's It's
I would rather allocate my team's effort
to growing something organic because it
is the most efficient form of growth in
terms of return on capital.
Not the easiest necessarily, but it's
the most efficient. So, if you can do
it, you do that. But most people can't
do it, and so they just do financial
arbitrage. But there's nothing wrong
with it. It's just a different way to
play the game. And so, private equity,
for example, will have traditionally
somewhere in the neighborhood between
five and 10 investments for a fund.
So, if you have a $500 million fund,
you're going to have five to 10
investments. And so, the fund size will
typically dictate the size of the
investment or check that they're going
to be writing.
Venture capital,
um and many times they have multiple
funds within one kind of uh fund, you
know, company, that will be start ones
for seed companies, ones for series A's,
ones for growth equity. Uh so, it just
depends on um
what stage of growth they're investing
in. But these companies can sometimes
have 50 to 100 investments per fund.
And so, because of that, they are
significantly more hands-off and more
betting on the few that go big, knowing
that they're going to have 99 losers and
one Facebook that's going to make up for
the whole fund.
Here, you really can't afford to lose
very much.
So, here they're looking for the very
consistent triples and quadruples and
five X's. Here they're looking for 100
or 1,000 X, and then a bunch of losers.
They're not obviously looking for
losers. Uh they're hoping for more
winners. Uh but fundamentally, that is
the difference in terms of the
investment thesis. And so, if you are
accepting a venture check, you have to
understand that those are the odds that
they are playing with and that they're
betting with on you that you like the
thing is is for them you are 1% bet. For
you, you're 100% bet. And so for the
investors, they can distribute their
outcome and diversify which decreases
their risk but also decreases their
upside. And if you happen to be Mark
Zuckerberg, then you will make more than
everyone else who invested in you. But
you got to be Mark Zuckerberg.
And so if we think about the CAC of
acquiring deals, the same advertising
laws always apply. And so you're going
to have
So you're going to have
four ways that you can get customers and
then four other ways we can leverage
other people to get you customers. And
so
if you look at acquisitions.com, if we
find a company that we think is
interesting, we'll reach out to them.
I post content like this video to
generate deal flow to get people to pay
attention to what we're doing and show
interest in our stuff. Uh we run paid
ads for the same reason. Um
now if I were a traditional private
equity firm, um I would probably have
affiliates or agencies. So these
agencies basically function as uh
brokers, right? Who will take a
percentage of the deal.
Um or there are kind of outbound
agencies that do this work too uh to
kind of like
um
bird dog deals. They go and chase out
They do a lot of this outbound stuff on
behalf of a private equity firm to
generate deal flow for them. And so in
all of the traditional advertising laws
apply. It's just that customers are now
deals and products are now companies.
And all you're doing is adding zeros to
your transactions.
And so APG, to be clear, used other
people's money. So they used, you know,
endowments from big universities like
Harvard and Yale and and you know, the
teachers fund uh to basically seed their
investment and they pool all of those
funds to then make the five or 10
investments they're going to make and
ultimately get a good return on it. But
it was other people's money
and other people's businesses.
And so for that, they didn't even have
to start any of these companies and they
were still able to make more money than
most founders do on their exits. So, APG
bought my company, other people's
businesses, using other people's money,
like the teachers endowments, the uh the
police fund, the firemen fund, the the
the you know, Yale, Princeton, Harvard,
the endowments that they have. They have
these massive war chests of money that
they give to these fund managers as a
small allocation of their overall
investment uh for their university or
for their limited for their for their
investees, if you will, um
to get a return.
And so, the key point that I think is
very interesting here is that
the fund manager of a fund like this
will often make more money
than any of the founders of the
businesses that they buy. And so, when I
when I saw that, I was like, "Oh, this
is a very high-leverage vehicle." And
so, this is what kind of kicked off my
journey to thinking through what are all
the ways to make mega money. And that
was the point of this video. And if you
liked this video and want to take any of
these four paths to mega money and you
want to compress the timeline that you
achieve it in, the number one video on
my channel talks about exactly how to do
it.